now the Star Wars actor John boyega is
swapping the red carpet to meet
teenagers at a youth center in South
London this evening it's for a project
organized by the onside charity which
runs facilities in disadvantaged areas
across the country and I'm delighted to
say he joins me now from South London
John it's great to have you on the
program thanks for speaking to us
to start with let us know tell us what
you're up to down there and why it's of
course so close to your heart
well Amazon teamed up with offside to
bring me down here to present more
opportunities and to really just support
the kids and the young people that come
down here for extracurricular activities
and we're at Legacy right now which is
an amazing spot where kids can come and
box they can cook they can basically do
a variety of things that inspires them
for the next stages of their lives so I
was invited down here because this is
also part of my purpose alongside with
the active and I've been meeting young
people we've done a big amazing um
giveaway that Amazon has provided where
it's just been a really brilliant night
no you're a bit of a role model in those
parts having grown up in South London
what are you hearing about what young
people are going through
well you know there definitely is a
sense of of feeling alone and there is a
sense of definitely feeling like there
aren't enough spaces around London where
young people can come for free
um and enjoy themselves away from the
academics away from school so you know
I've been talking to a lot of people a
lot of them are between the ages of 13
to 19 and they've been coming down here
they've been coming down here to you
know she just gets nice it's all right
bro bro that's one of the young people
that just come down here to just get a
new sense of life and just get a variety
of opportunities that are available to
them so you know sorry the bit be a
habit but this is the youth center this
is a youth center we love a bit of Havoc
very nice I'll give you a shout if I see
a ball flying towards you
um just tell us
a Dodge what was what was it that made
the difference uh for you you know
having grown up in South London and then
obviously becoming a Hollywood star John
what was it that helped get you on that
path
um definitely it was the facilities
outside of school the youth groups like
this like Legacy it was me going to a
place called theater Peckham where I was
introduced into a world of tap
contemporary ballet it was going to
Identity drama school that which was the
first drama school I went to that was
two days a week
um I'll be honest with you if I didn't
have those opportunities I would not be
in this position talking to you today so
I just understand how important this is
and now to be graced to be in this
position it's a great opportunity for me
to give back and also at the same time
learn in terms of me how I'm going to be
able to be of help to these young people
who are now in these facilities looking
for looking for options you know looking
to be inspired and to be motivated and
now John you spoke publicly during
um the black lives matter rallies how
much is racism still an issue for young
black people and the opportunities they
have
I mean we can see still see an endless
cycles of the lack of opportunities for
young black people but I think what
we're realizing here is that also
there's a class issue too you know a lot
of people living in environments where
they just don't have the exposure to
options um and you know what that does
that limits the options that you have
especially leaving uni um so this is a
vital time 13 and 19 to be able to get
these kids aware of cooking aware of
cinematography aware of these different
spaces within different types of skill
sets and careers just inspires them and
gets them ready for to make a choice of
how they're going to imply what role
they play in the world and then how
they're going to join Society in the
most healthy way so this has just been
inspirational for me to meet people from
all walks of life actually there's been
people white Blacklist with loads of
people but what brings them all together
is the lack of opportunity in their area
and that's what I've been I've been
listening to tonight
yeah it's really great what you're doing
uh John and in terms of
um the World Cup of course which is
taking place at the moment
um how encouraged are you by the number
of great black Role Models there are now
like yourself like Marcus rashford is
that encouraging for you
definitely I think um when I was growing
up we we didn't have enough of that we
didn't have people who would come from
my environment who had gone to a space
in which uh was dreamy or successful we
had a limited amount of names but we
didn't have anybody that came back in
and and basically touched home that the
way these people have Marcus included I
just think it's important it's
inspiration and it's not only for them
it's for me too I'm still a young person
who's trying to figure it out and
sometimes meeting these young people
meeting these kids and them sharing
their perspective makes me more
appreciative of where I am today and
then it gives me more more peace to be
able to decide how I'm going to help
them you know achieve what they want to
achieve it's not every day a Hollywood
star turns up in Croydon unannounced
what was the reaction like when you
arrived today
no they they went crazy they went crazy
there was there was loads of laughter
um and I had an opportunity thanks to
Legacy to just talk to each individual
child and just you know just Vibe and
have a conversation with them um it was
a lot of listening today actually you
know you think you come in and just give
them a big speech give them inspiration
stay in school go home but I was just
listening to their stories and there's a
lot of amazing young people down here a
lot of amazing young people
well it's been a real pleasure to speak
to you uh John best of luck with the
work you're doing down there and mind
out for those balls
no no thank you so much thank you